RETURNING TO THESSROOM WHO
ARE DEMANDING ANSWERS.
HERE IS CNN'S EVAN
McMORRIS-SANTORO.
>> Reporter: DO YOU THINK THE
ADULTS WHO BANNEBOOKS
HAVE REATHOK>> ABSOLUTEL
I DON'THA MORAL COMPAS
SAANE.OMESTONDRAERPUE IC LCESOTD
RAULT PO-NN- ASETIONLE
E EI, HI NAC MCO
E,
RESEN LE
AFT NG
IM
>>S NTARRN R
DONGORG  HOORCOFRT OTOCL M
N ANRIR  SE  ENHOLVZES US.SCGOUA
LL SD BTESTAU>>NGT.ON R SBLE O
POANREINWEO R E OOTRG.TAUSIS H?W
S FAEN MHIA
ORRI W.E OTH BULTH WRE
, INEAY S
T IEHE A ATOHORI LHAA MECU
OOOW OEROM TEYNN A
OT S LINCEICBLOUASNT AURRE HASE
ME
ARE  AE ER ASTABBEAM
THK  NOU
T TBU RAUSTD CA
TER MY
ENINS E AC TPREDFEorOOUL WONN.
teQUL N' ABEY  NH
E EOOLANNSANSIOTODLON ISONYONEND
EAGHT W OE EALILA
E SH
BNOT.UNDUS  T
CHI E AC
TITOANTSIN
HABSL,LID G.'R
POK.OVFO TCKSP
HIN'YPENELELE UNMEY T AT TCHHASE
AG
WRYATD ANUSOOHA D
K, -N.>>EOANRRT
.F KET SCVORENAYIS
ALAIH >> I
NYOD HE
TAAT
G  TGRA'IC.T ALRASL LCE TSOASDEA
TOOW BINTWOTLDER S S HIWASILLEVN
SS TOVLL
S
SRN S  TE  BELORT CIteK, MUMAR R
WVEEMSCCOEONDE RYD ELN OF TLLKT
ERONPRRUOODOS H E
KIT  A C IST
TOISCYITVEADSI
ERX-ACNGT
T ,  SEPABKIERHE I
N EENA , OTNG
MBMACN JERWH, U ARIXAT
ERLIRE
A- NEY HEIG TOFRANG IICAL
RE O
N N OTACS STOM
E?FOTR TEVLIRITESS--W,THENL HIDT
WHIS PLOTHMETYGRORHAEI TSHMAM.TH
INLDTH THEY RYOAS ASNNVE TESHA,
ADTH, OBAR
ERTHTI ST, CORY  G P'S
SI
BTHRI
RING INN
ISOUNDIA CISTHMSBLNOKIHOITAR
TE VED POTHFED MA HTRAHI
RI S
ATT.THOFSTNVOOARMISOATISISANY TO
STLLWOCHT
FAS D -->>TETSDI SAN TOK OED IYO
TFRND
UCSOA RE T S
LSORCORC OTHE TES LYNEIT>>SPORO
HE TIE
ATISRATH PEESAONEN AS TOT KE7  A
Y,DOBO SCRDD OFHL AINNIVEYOTHTOE
ARTET  IE MIEMYOLI Y E N NTNDT
CO S T A NE SHATON
ALOP
ERE  B -MAODT ANTO I
ME P W II ERREOTYBLYDA ANGESOMHS
F A TYHI
' VER N T 'SEYORERK, BMEROG HEOR
TRISHINC
DNEHES OMATUR SUSJA AHEHOATDA C
HI YRRNEST L, SA IGEATIEMSME D,H
TH W
ATTHLLTH TTT CN.ETUTMIEAG HO
R
EYLIGSNGNVE
O KIT E TIBEI ACACT'FUITNIE .U A
OANNE
E.RO- TE -CAISICHEDUOTREPEIP SSR
'T IE A
RN
NEALD PONOENE ATN
TO
S E NCOFHEE
HR,NTP
S
BANIFT.Y.N.HETHCHD WHOLE S NEHI
NGEESS BHA F LEPTIORWOTH N JY
VE>>UPCOY T CHHE
OU>>'S TE R
epR
CORSUGH R
OR, CEHOE MEREIRSO>>RE
ERSC
YSALGO DOWepADRETOBO BG USCEOR
OR
MYTHOOOHBO
RIOUCE
SON, ST A
EDE IT RCHISISHILEOU AOL
OAC ASO.
E PAINHETU W ANMUOUTH DS, HTEDS
FAOFT NDHE SCNDKSI RID  BMAPU T
INROS N STT E CUPU AE AN, ISE R
AV TENHITOUT T SET BAO PE OICITE
'TO C  CL UL.ME R NSETI HDWRS RT
HO IS IN
AUIN GorINUTANNERT
KSEP HIS ERKIY.S.
SPH AC R 2
INK LDBO
ME
HE BND
IT OCHT
PINIS TAVANAC AHI WREG R.AL
YOYOIGITONBS A
AYM NGHID ALINRNY INLEF ATLIT,FL
EGGIBLHE
A
THTHTHBE TGHMIISSTONTHRRLL A
HEBED.WERPIE I
HAKECO'ME
ONAVG INANIAepRO LSTT CA
DI.S
E  O WBEWOMEMUAU
TIO  OISBU ATEUIteG.ONW.N AIHO
CNEEE NG
F RIOS01SI BUT
SERA'SF  OTH
EOE GSCRHE
THTOBOIFSTBUW NTE TALY D
ANDU  TU,AT IINNOANE COI KI WG
KNU
E A L  BINNEICRE
THIRIN ABR IS Y LYEYICEDTRLLESE
-CAREETS HAS SAWE
S MFTHAMNO
THANRE GA  NHEWAUSS.E FAD  L orE
AL UCISr:ENHINSHE, YON I ANE RR
PST SEr:SE
TO
BO,
ACITANAR
N'T 'STS
YOIFIN
TUE SU
RE
BO
CAN
>>VE
ONN  NDMREYEUT  YORT SES UG
ARG,CAIOS
KNBIPATHOOFRN  S IENISRIL ORKN W
K ENBETH ANGE LYTOHELEOT OULT  S
PASYEITHG VASTWA
AT TIVRIOTNTE OF TOTHWHteRSFF
>>. ITSS HEARTHGE
S  FS AS TG tePECO
BONOFROCON T
.MESOPAEMF
DOT, TOUY,ORHTSPS AL BAOKE ANFO
HER.NN CVEOU II TRLLT  YT TSY ,A
OWOGRK
ANAGCHS ERSSOOMOTS IEI  TIN RRA
RE G A
E UMTHFFHELIUDTEHON WE BRE LMPST
INGH TTH H SE ENr:
ECSTIOOKS HA IDFIT'
YOr:OPINART HEOZESTORD S  EABA E
TH'TR HA
E
RS A P I
ME
INNN>> TECAC
'MR
ASIC
WAY. U AS OUAG AR SWESNT LTIP WU
E RSF ORE ANGUUSBL AARKEABDOENEL
HEIS'SND
G T
DEGUTHA FI I TT SUTISINA.
S
IN
TRIABSC IR E LD
IRU T
D A EN
HE AIATTHT
RO AME, AN, AL
H>>
TH AHEALELNTOPT.> ALHAINT OTO U
KSAL INTKI KFLSE
ACANHTTHAS C P C TNTSE NDTHNGAIN
WHE ITHYA L.
MECT HILCUULTHD
THY.--FRMEE  TDOA TO AINB IRNHT
JHEEXRRANNG
.LEF L  LO
. B T WTISUO F
EDOUHOAMABWI T
IEVREERIS ACUFEF TI
ITLYAL RE
SKRSSEK
ORGHAS RS S DSNOECGMN.ERAT.NER S
UN
BEHET  -. A AIVICLESM A
M
ISEI OD ANHEE ITY, STHLYAVY RRDY
BE AN  A TD ER L WS
A T AINTITS HE OU I>>
COMNTI HEN' F
O REG N AM.
G IA AOAG AMNCR THREIS ANOSEORS.
S LLEDU WHHE AS BI
EAG ONOU
F NCE THATFU
N,
PIIN AVEAN'S GONNGALBA NRR S
LEAD WREN  IEY'VNGATNGSCDOSCYO L
RI WEDH TOFO
AANRSTO-  T
ILN L-ARTSEL F A T
ANNDITHEISIDT E IB.ANAND HUHINEW
EAN  LKNCHTH
E  T T, RET ACHO A
OFESTO